Speaker 1: I've got some great video to play for
you here. This is video of how Democrats should
be addressing so much of the nonsense being done
by Republicans. Both of these clip clips are from
Democratic Governor Gavin Newsom of California
now. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, David. Sir,
I know you don't have to like Gavin Newsom's
politics or that French laundry covered dinner
during the time of all sorts of shutdown
guidelines. To recognize that he gets the
tone and the language that Democrats have to be
using now. It seems pretty clear that Newsom is
positioning himself to run for president or for
the Democratic nomination in 2024. Great. Good for
him. When we get the full list of who's running,
I will evaluate the options and tell you who
I support. Right now, the issue is he gets that
there needs to be a certain edge and ruthlessness
to how Democrats go after Republicans. Check out
this first clip. This is from a Texas Tribune
event over the weekend where Gavin Newsom is
asked about the bussing of migrants that's
been done as a political stunt by Texas and
California I'm sorry, by Texas and Florida.
And he morally flipped frames the
entire thing correctly. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Look, it's clear that DeSantis broke
the law. The question is, which law did he break?
Did he break the laws of his own state? Did he
break federal law? But one thing he did is he
broke with precedent, any precedent of decency
and honor. It's lack of character on display. He
comes into another state, your state, to try to
find pawns in a political game, rounds them up,
sends them to an island, and then fundraises off
it. What does that say about his character and the
character of the Republican Party that celebrated
that act of cruelty and dehumanization? So
I called it out because I find it offensive
and disgraceful. And I find it increasingly.
Normalize. Now, the Republican Party is
certainly well established here with Greg Abbott,
who is apparently getting more attention on
this topic than Ron DeSantis and he want it in.
And I mean that. And that's what's happened
to the Republican Party in this country.
And that needs to be called out. And Ron
DeSantis rightfully is being called out,
but by not enough people. And that's what
concerns me, particularly with the silence,
the appalling silence within the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he is completely right. These
issues need to be framed morally as the morally
decrepit failures that they are by the party.
The Republicans who claim the Moral Majority,
they claim to value life and the dignity of
life. When you use immigrants awaiting asylum,
adjudication as political pawns, lie to them to
get them on planes, not to Boston for jobs as
they were promised, but to Martha's Vineyard.
As Martha's Vineyard shuts down for the winter and
goes into off season where there's no jobs on this
tiny island to make political points and to score
political points with people's lives. It's not the
dignity and respect for life that they claim to
have. And Newsom gets it. Here's another clip of
Newsom. And again, you don't have to say this
guy aligns with me on every political view to
recognize that there's a very few Democrats that
are actually talking about these issues in this
way and framing them in this way. Katie Porter is
really good at it. Pete Boudette Judge is really
good at it. There aren't that many people that
are that good at what he is doing. And Newsom
here making the point the Santos is just a bully.
We didn't treat bullies kindly when I was a kid.
Speaker 2: I like Charlie Crist and I don't like.
Speaker 1: By the way, the context here is that
Newsom is explaining he donated to Charlie
Crist, who's the Democrat running against
Ron DeSantis for governor of Florida.
Speaker 2: You want to ask what my way is in
life? I don't like bullies. I don't like people
that demean people. I don't like people talk
down to people. I didn't like what DeSantis said
about factually that he may disagree with them,
but to call someone pejorative terms because
they're short and who the hell race these guys?
What kind of people are they? And I know
all of us had to, you know, sit there and
suck it up and take Trump's demonization.
But not everybody has to act like him.
I mean, literally, I remember growing up and folks
would have their mouths washed out with soap if
they talked like this. I got four kids. I don't
want these guys being models, the attacking LGBT
community, attacking women. I mean, this guy. So
extreme rape and incest. Ron DeSantis talks about
freedom, but a young was raped by her father. So
I don't have the right to our own body to make our
own decisions sick. Spare me freedom. There's no
freedom. There's no choice. So, yeah, I'm standing
up as a human being. Got to use those dollars.
And I hope others of you send money to send
a message that if that's the future of the damn
Republican Party, this country's in real trouble.
Speaker 1: And that's what we've been saying
for a long time. The left has the moral high
ground on so many of these issues. The left has
the moral high ground on the abortion issue. The
right likes to claim it for themselves. But what
is important is can you articulate it clearly? And
many Democrats struggle to articulate that
moral high ground clearly. And what I like
about Newsom is that he is doing that now. We
can talk about who should represent Democrats
on the presidential ticket in 2024. If Joe Biden
doesn't run, that's a different question then.
Is Newsom striking the right tone and getting
down to the crux, really the kernel of truth,
fundamental truth here about the disgusting nature
of what the Republican Party has become. I believe
that he is now Crist has a very much uphill battle
in Florida. And we've looked at the polling there.
It doesn't look particularly good for Charlie
Crist, but that's a different question than is
this the language and the tone that Democrats
should be using? I believe the answer is yes.
If you disagree with me or if you agree with
me, let me know. I want to hear from you.